congratulations on this role i've i mean
the fan reaction to you has just been
fantastic how are you feeling
amazing i mean it's just been incredible
to to watch and be a part of yeah
it's it's a little bit overwhelming at
times but i'm yeah i'm just really
enjoying this moment
and listening to how much everyone's
engaging with the show and the character
it's
yeah it's brilliant you sure you're a
loki you're in my way
you are my way
what did you know about the role when
you auditioned did you know exactly what
it would be
nothing i knew absolutely nothing i
didn't know what the show was i didn't
know about the role i didn't
i didn't know anything there was some
there was a very short scene
um between two people bob and sarah i
think it was on a train i mean it ended
up being the train scene between loki
and silvie but
i had no idea what i was auditioning for
wow so when did you find out that it was
marvel and loki so i mean they they kind
of
told me that they liked what i did and
i'd worked with kate before so
um by that time you know kate was like
you know
this is the show this is what i've been
working on and she told me a little bit
more about
it and then i met with tom on facetime
and then you know when they offered me
the job kate just told me
the whole story and about the character
and just gave me the whole pitch
so it wasn't until i'd been offered the
job that i knew what
it was tell me about that face time with
tom and
if there's something that comes to mind
was there a piece of like advice or
anything he said about
joining the marvel universe you know
what that whole facetime is like a fever
dream i can barely remember it i was
like nine months pregnant and
he was in new york and i was in london
and
it was just a sort of chat we talked for
possibly an hour
and we talked about everything like life
and
mutual friends people that we knew that
knew each other or you know we covered a
lot of ground
and i i hadn't been offered the job at
that point
so there wasn't that much advice that he
could give me i mean that came
later but he has given me a lot of
advice since and it's been super helpful
um you know just stuff about having fun
with it and you know putting
you know putting my my stamp on it and
making selfie my own and you know
you know not being afraid to sort of
improvise and to sort of add on
and and because you know marvel and
disney are both really open to that and
um open to that way of working which is
great because i love
i love all that stuff yeah yeah and tom
clearly has so much fun
playing loki did you i mean sylvie's
obviously a different
character but was there anything that
you saw in tom hiddleston's
portrayal that you infused into sylvia
at all i think
like you say watching tom peloki you can
tell how much fun he's having and how
much he's enjoying like the mischievous
of the
mischievousness of it and the chaotic
nature of it
so i tried to i definitely tried to
channel that in my own way and just
really have fun with it and have fun
with sylvie's sort of like cheekiness
and her sarcasm
and um yeah the mischief and
and the chaos um and just go with it
and so yeah i definitely was inspired by
that
watching you two just play off each
other is such a joy
one of my favorite things about this
show or the marvel shows in general is
there since they're week to week there's
this place for like fan theories and
just like reddit wormholes
have you been following along with all
the fan theories so far and do you have
a favorite that you've read
i mean you know it's impossible to
follow everything because there's so
much stuff
um i dip in though and i try and sort of
you know
have an eye on what people are thinking
um
there was one i heard earlier actually
about the postman
something about in in episode three
sylvie says something about
a postman that she's been having a
long-distance
relationship with like she's being
sarcastic basically
but there's been a whole theory about
who this postman might be
and where he is and if he's going to
make an appearance and that's the theory
that i'm
really enjoying you will latch on to
anything
well in marvel we're like we're so used
to kind of
directly pinning a character to its
comic source and just going off of that
so how much fun have you had you're kind
of playing a new character that's maybe
like an amalgam of
of one or more characters how much fun
are you having with that oh so much fun
it's great it's nice to you know be
playing
a new character with a new backstory and
you know
lo the series of loki is definitely
inspired by the comics but
the whole story is new um everything is
um you know yeah a new story for a bit
for us to tell and for people to enjoy
and it's it's wonderful yeah it's really
exciting
i did a bit of research and i re-watched
the films and that kind of thing but
i it was important for me to make sylvia
a unique character
so i really wanted to you know have fun
with it and
and sort of start from scratch in a way
and kate was really supportive of that i
was just like so do whatever you want
you know play have fun
you know we'll tell you if you you know
if it's bad
that kind of thing or perhaps another
prince
a bit of both i suspect the same as you
loki confirms he's bisexual in the
series and sylvie seemingly
confirms that as well what did it mean
to you to be a part of that moment
because it was such a monumental moment
in marvel
huge it's hugely important for me and to
so many people and you know
representation is so powerful and it's
been a long time coming and
i'm very proud that i've been a part of
finally
you know loki coming out you don the
iconic one
horned crown what was the moment like
when you had kind of everything on for
the first time what did that feel like
it felt pretty good you know i felt like
uh yeah okay now i'm silvy
watch out stay out of my way i think
something happens when i
put the outfit on and um
it's definitely like the icing on the
cake for me acting wise
you know something happens and sylvie
comes out
i love that you're you're enchanting in
this role so it's all working
thank you so much so lovely videos
ashley that's nice you too lovely to
meet you
thank you